maryland is trying to ease some of the
gas pains that its drivers are having at
the pump the nationwide average is now
clocking in at
4.27 per gallon for unleaded regular
that's up 48 percent from one year ago
on friday governor larry hogan signed a
bill to suspend the state's gasoline tax
for 30 days
and while cost savings is on the minds
of most drivers it's especially a factor
for so-called hyper milers these drivers
take their time to get the best bang for
their gasoline buck chris van cleave
takes us along for the ride
southern california is home to the
nation's highest gas prices nearly two
dollars a gallon higher than a year ago
are you really getting 87 miles to the
gallon yeah i'm getting well over 80
miles per gallon
wayne gerdes is serious about making his
tank go further about 60 percent further
than what the epa says his plug-in prius
hybrid should be getting this is very
much a slow and steady approach to
driving yeah
you've hit it with that
we are on interstate 5 outside san diego
what does 55 miles per hour mean to you
means you're going a lot slower than
everybody else on the road
that's okay they're not buying my gas
he says always follow the speed limit
speed kills fuel economy it does there's
no way around it curtis is one of the
nation's leading hypermilers folks who
take fuel economy to the extreme
some try to reduce drag drop weight even
draft behind semis wayne often coasts
downhill the optics can be bad to other
drivers
because it's not the normal pattern that
we all follow most of the tips in the
hyper milers playbook are smart the goal
is stay moving gently accelerating and
we start slowly breaking well before a
red light cruising through it as it
turns green during our drive around town
he averaged 110 miles per gallon on city
streets
it all adds up curtis saves about twenty
five hundred dollars a year every dollar
i save in fuel is dollar in my pocket
wayne drives for a living so he is on
the road a ton and when gas prices are
hitting 629 like they are at this
station little things start to matter
that's why you want to think about the
junk in your trunk and get rid of it
carrying a bunch of stuff around like
driving a whole other person and that
can result in fewer miles per gallon
for cbs saturday morning i'm chris van
cleave in los angeles
get rid of that junk in your trunk
that's a real savings it is when you
start looking at the number 500
how much is gas in l.a right now i think
i saw yesterday a friend of mine posted
a station had for
and
7.19
cents and a lot of that is gas tax i'm
clearly not a hyper miler because i was
trying to get to the airport on two
occasions for stories and i was well i
was and you made it well above lead foot
there yeah
that's for sure